the Tom Cruise has been on the show a
number of times and he is incredible
when he shines his lights on so to learn
how to be a movie star off someone like
amazing to learn from him yeah yeah best
possible teacher thing because was it it
wasn't someone in the cast who had the
accident
oh gosh no he was late for rehearsal
he's saving people all the time yeah he
was late for rehearsal and it had been
raining which is a miracle cuz that
doesn't happen anymore in Los Angeles
and there'd been an accident on the road
in front of him and there was a woman
who'd been hit actually she was crossing
the street and and he of course he got
out of his car and ran to see that she
was okay and came at him being her on
the road and when you come to there's
Tom Cruise you're dead right sure but so
yeah he took her to the hospital and it
turned out it cuz she didn't have health
insurance which is a thing you know you
guys probably heard about that
yeah so anyway she didn't have health
insurance so but he took care of it made
sure she was sorta Gompers
yeah are you still on the Tom Cruise
cake list you're on the Tom Cruise cake
lift you know I didn't know we're on the
Tom Cruise cake list so today I was
talking about you being on the cake list
and somebody says oh yeah we got a cake
from Tom every year and do we
someone in the office but it's the
nicest cake I've ever well I'll call you
in mind comes next
I've never seen Tom Cruise cake with
cakes cuz my cousin worked with Tom
Cruise and he got cakes so he must have
shares in a bakery surely my granny
turned a hundred and then we arrived and
there are a hundred cakes there from Tom
Cruise what'd ya get cupcakes oh yeah I
was gonna say
she's lived long enough yeah it must be
it must be some way of spreading joy and
and using cakes bring joy I haven't had
the joy really impressed I'm Kirsten
Dunst has been on the show and you know
like it's so long ago since she worked
them she still gets the cake with a
vampire she was a child it still gets
the cake and my hundred-year-old granny
she's dead now it was a few years this
is still get the cake Tom Cruise outside
the funeral home there's a stack of
cakes no the she she she didn't Tom
Cruise didn't mean that much to her
she's of an older generation if she said
please tell your friend that I loved the
cakes it was so nice to receive them it
was just sort of to her it was just this
random guy who goes around giving cakes
to people didn't realize it's Tom Cruise
yeah like a character from Sesame Street
something yeah
[Music]